est-ce que pour être heureux il est
nécessaire de se
droguer c'est une de question faut
demander un petit peu à des
spécialistes il a choisi de tourner le
dos à la société il est ce qu'on appelle
[Musique]
Hipi il y a 7 mois il furent vouloir
rompre avec tout à Paris l'actrice de
cinéma Valérie Lagrange leur a donné de
l'argent alors ils ont acheté pour 30000
francs les trois/4 d'un village en ruine
le vieux noyer dans les Alpes de Haute
Provence et depuis ils vivent au rythme
de la terre et semble-t-il ils vivent
heureux hein qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
heureux est-ce que pour être heureux il
est nécessaire de se
droguer c'est une drôle de question faut
demander un petit peu à des spécialistes
timoéon a 5 mois et demi c'est le
premier enfant né dans cette communauté
i au papillon et quand il estta revenu
il avait un grand sac avec des PAP le
village de noyer sur chabron bien vivant
lui tout le monde n'apprécie pas
vraiment cette faç de
papillon je voudrais être un peu
l'interprète de la population
authentique de noyer n'est-ce pas je
vous avou qu'il ne voit pas d'un très
bon œil ces gens venus du dehors qui
changent constamment et qui n'ont pas
d'occupation fixe alors que les gens du
pays sont des travailleurs des gros
travailleurs comme tous les paysans
n'est-ce pas leur mur donne beaucoup à
dire ça vous gêne de savoir qu'il se
baignent nuus ça nous gêne ça nous gêne
non seulement ils se baignent mais ils
font nouvelle meurs autre façon de vivre
voir il n'y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil il y a rien à inventer tu vois
tout ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on fait tout
ce qu'on peut faire tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est déjà fait c'est déjà dit
et ces hipis ont agi trois maisons sont
retapées et habitées quatre autres en
réflexion deux jardins donnent des
légumes 3 hectares de terre ont été
défrichés irrigués labourés est préparé
à la semaille il y a des lapins des
poules des moutons 10 ruches personne ne
meurt de faim même si la vie est
frugale mais pourquoi vivent-il comme
ça pourquoi mais je sais pas
moi je sais pas mais la réponse elle est
là dans la nature dans la
nature tuaelle ça comme tu
veux ça durera longtemps ah bah la
nature ça dure depuis avant même que toi
et moi on soit là tu et votre façon de
vivre est-ce qu'elle durera
longtemps dans son temps on sera tous
[Musique]
morts les saints aussi avaient appris la
pauvreté cespieux ont redécouvert deux
vertus des pauvres l'hospitalité et
[Musique]
l'amitié chacun sait pourquoi il a tout
quitté aucun ne sait ce qu'il va trouver
mais tous ensemble ils cherchent leur
voix avec une certitude une vie
librement choisie et toujours meilleur
qu'une vie
imposée
[Musique]